- I'm gonna be honest and
look, I'm not a pop culture,
I never know what's happening.
And I was reading my script
last night I was like, "What?"
I had no idea y'all were dating.
And I'm very, I don't know
why I'm excited about this.
It's kind of weird that I would be excited
about this because I don't
know y'all that well,
but I just love it.
Two comedians, like dating.
Who's the funniest at home?
Come on.
- This one.
- Okay.
- Oh. Well, no.
We're both. I mean, I'm bitchy
funny, you know what I mean?
- Which is funny.
- He's funny-funny.
He's like sweet, funny,
good natured funny.
And then I come in and I'm like, you know-
- Yeah. She just knocks down all the pins.
- Go for the jugular?
- Yeah.
- It's like, "Here comes
bowling ball," and it's Chelsea.
- Yeah.
- I just think this will
be the greatest show
ever to watch.
So wait, so do you remember
the first time y'all met, Joe?
- Yeah. It was a long, long time.
Here's the thing I remember.
She doesn't remember.
- Well, first of all, shut up. Okay?
Second, I remember, what I do remember,
Kelly, is that this very studio was
where we filmed "Chelsea Lately"
For like 4 or 5 years.
- Yes.
And, Joe, what I do remember
is Joe was a regular
on that show.
He was on my round table all the time.
'Cause we had comedians on
and he was one of the best.
- There was no chemistry
then? There was a...
- Well, he says I had a crush
on him during that time.
I also don't recall that, you know?
- She doesn't recall anything.
- [Kelly] Unless it's
what, a selective memory?
- We met through a mutual
friend, Jon Lovitz.
- Okay. Yes.
- And Jon Lovitz
was doing a show at the Laugh Factory.
He's like, "You have to meet
Chelsea. She's hysterical."
(Kelly laughing)
"She's my only friend on MySpace."
- On MySpace?
- MySpace. So then I went to MySpace.
It was really Chelsea.
And then she started coming
on the shows and she told
me about the show that she
was about to develop and,
long story short, she came up with an idea
that I was supposed to be on
the show and then I turned
it down and she just hated me forever.
- He says, I wanted, I
asked him to be my sidekick.
Remember Chewy?
- Yeah.
- He was my little nugget sidekick?
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- Well, apparently, I went
to him first and Joe turned
me down and then I hired Chewy.
- So, yeah.
- You missed out?
- But she doesn't remember any of that.
- Not gonna have all
this love for that long.
- Mm-hmm.
- Shame on you, Joe.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- I used to sit there.
The panel used to be right here.
She used to be right
here and I used to look
at her like this.
- Oh, I loved your show.
So not, oh my gosh.
- He did, he did. He had a crush on me.
I knew that. And...
(Kelly laughs)
But I was never gonna get
involved with somebody
on my round table.
You know? I mean, to me, they
were just like comic boys.
And I was like they were, it
was almost like I was the,
a parent in like that dynamic, you know?
I mean, I'm sure nobody thought
of me as their mother, but-
- Do you play mommy now or?
I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
We're gonna take that out.
Sorry.
- Actually, I think we
should leave that in, Kelly.
- We're keeping it daytime. No.
So, wait, have y'all met
each other's families yet?
- Oh, yeah.
I mean, I've met his
family from years ago.
But, yeah, we've met each...
- He was with us home for
Christmas in Whistler.
My whole family came to Whistler.
- Oh my gosh. I love Whistler.
- Oh yeah. I love it too.
- That's where your family lives?
- Yeah. Well, no.
That's where we go for
holidays 'cause I love to ski.
- I went there one year
with my family. Yeah.
- Yeah. It's beautiful.
- I used to snowboard.
Now, I'm not doing that.
- Not anything.
- No, not athletic.
- She's like, "No."
- I thought I knew how to ski 'cause I was
from Vegas and I used to
ski at Mount Charleston.
- Why did you think you could
ski from Vegas? (laughs)
Wait, have you taught him how to ski?
- Well. We, he came up to.
Skiing is very important to me.
I'm very passionate about it.
- Really?
- So, when he came up
to Whistler, I said,
"Listen, I know you think.
I know you..."
- Oh my god. You're a snow bunny.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I said to him when he
came out to Whistler, I go-
- I would ski if I look
like that. (laughs)
- Yeah. That's my bikini.
- [Kelly] Maybe if I ski,
I will look like that.
That's gonna be, did you
dress like this as well?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. We
had matching outfits.
- How did he do? Skiing.
- Well, we threw him into
the, I said, "Listen.
I know you think you've skied,
but Vegas is not skiing.
So, stop talking about Vegas."
- First of all,
she acts like there's no
mountains with snows in the...
She goes, "Where'd you
learn Circus Circus?"
It's like, no, I didn't learn
how to ski at Circus Circus.
- In all honesty, no one says Vegas
when you say, "Man, I had
this great snow trip."
(audience laughing)
- Exactly.
- That's true.
- You're alone. On an island.
Happy Valentine's Day.
Once again, everybody.
But was Valentine's Day a big
deal for y'all growing up?
And is it a big deal for y'all like now?
- I mean, no, first of all,
it was, when I was growing up,
I liked the action of,
you know when you were a
little girl in elementary
school and you had to
hand out all those cards
to different boys?
- [Kelly] I do that with my kids, yeah.
I was the, that was like,
when I got the party started, I-
- I never got that card.
(Chelsea and Kelly laughing)
Never.
- When I was a girl, like
third or fourth grade,
I love that, you get all the
Valentine's, and you give
all the Valentines, you know?
And then as I grew up, I was like,
this is such a stupid holiday.
You know?
Like making, forcing people to be romantic
on days, you know?
- It's forced fun.
- It's too manufactured.
- Yeah.
- So, I-
- It's pressure.
- I appreciate people who
are single on this holiday.
Like, please, have as much fun as possible
because it's just such a
silly I mean, obviously,
I'm in love with you, and I'm happy to...
But don't...
- Hey man, it shows.
(Chelsea and Kelly laughing)
- You're really selling it, honey.
- But don't go overboard.
- [Kelly] Oh my god. You all need a show.
- Let me get rid of these.
(Kelly laughing)
- We hate flowers and cards.
- I don't know what I was thinking.
I bought her flowers and...
- I don't like any organized thing
where people say, on this
day, you must do this.
- It's pressure.
I don't like, I love giving gifts.
It stresses me out so much
to have a planned thing.
Like, I don't know why,
but do you get each other
gifts or y'all not doing that?
'Cause here's my thing. At some
point, you can buy your own.
Like, it's like, I'm always,
like, I can buy my own stuff.
I don't need you to buy me some.
I'd rather have something
like, I don't know.
I like something made or like a card,
or like something like that.
- Yeah. I always appreciate
a card with writing.
- Like meaningful.
- Yeah.
Much more than any gift.
- Yeah. 'Cause you could
buy your own stuff.
- Exactly. And I do.
- It's me too. (laughs)
- Yeah. And we do, we should, yeah.
And also, like I think
another point about singledom
and the people, the woman
who was talking earlier
in your audience about being single,
like please I can't
tell single women enough
to enjoy your singledom.
You are not gonna be single for long.
Nobody's ever single forever, you know?
So, enjoy and embrace it
and use it as that time
to prepare for the guy or
the girl that's coming.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah. Okay.
So I love, though, like I've
seen your eyes when I said,
gifts and like are you
gonna like just trash
the gift you got her?
'Cause like, you were like backing up.
You're like, "Yeah, gifts are
dumb. Nobody gives gifts."
- No. She loves it.
she it's you when you
surprise her the right way,
she enjoys it.
- Yeah. That's true.
- There's a lot of thought
behind it and then yeah.
But, if you're just getting
her a bunch of stuff,
she doesn't like that.
- There is no quicker
way to make me angry.
- Yeah.
- Than like a last minute,
oh I, and I'm like, did you
literally swing by a store?
I really would've rather had nothing.
- [Joe] Yeah.
- It's like, you know, when
they get you something,
and you're like, there was
no thought into this at all.
- But, even like writing
her a card is hard
because she's so, like, her
vocabulary is so extensive.
- Who cares?
- And it's like-
- Love is gentle.
- It's like,
she's getting, it's like,
you're getting graded.
It's like, she pulls out a red pen.
It's like, "Nope, this doesn't make sense.
You need a punctuation here."
- There are too many
propositional phrases.
- Yeah.
- I am a bit of a-
- What's this word? What?
- It's love.
- I'm a bit of a buzzkill with that kind
of stuff, you know?
He'll be like, "Come
over here and lay down."
I'm like, "It's lie down!"
I'll come over there
when you say it right.
- I don't know why he's laughing.
I know you say lay down too.
- I love it.
I really wanna see a
show with y'all in it.
So wait, let's talk about
your comedy tours 'cause
I'm very excited.
Yours is called "Vaccinated
and Horny," which is-
- I came up with the name,
Vaccinated and Horny
before I was with Joe.
So, now, my horniness is
only directed at one person.
- [Kelly] Yes. Now you have a vessel.
Yes. Very, yeah.
- So I'm still vaccinated,
I'm still horny. Yeah.
- Happy Valentine's Day.
Happy Valentine's Day.
(audience cheering)
- For you.
So, wait, yours is called,
Funny is Funny, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Okay. So, why did you name yours that?
- I just, that's how I think
you should look at life.
Funny is funny.
It doesn't matter who you
are, what you look like,
what religion, what color.
Funny is funny.
- Agreed. Yeah.
- It's the best language.
- Yeah. We both-
- I enjoy the laugh.
- No, laughter is medicine.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- And we get to go on tour separately.
And then sometimes, we pop
up at each other's shows.
- [Kelly] I was gonna ask
y'all. Do y'all do that?
- So It's really fun when
we do a show, like we just,
I mean, we just did a show in Seattle,
and it was a surprise, like,
for me to come up, you know?
And he had 14,000 people in the audience
so it was a incredible night
and that's his hometown.
So yeah, people get really
excited when we were able
to pop up on each other's shows too.
But yeah, we're both on
tour at the same time.
So, our schedules are, it's
just like the perfect thing.
I never, ever, thought
I would be able to date
a male comedian, you know?
- I, that's what I was gonna say.
Did you ever think y'all would
date a comedian? She said no.
Did you ever think you'd date a comedian?
- No, I never, no. I never
thought I would date her.
That's...
(audience laughs)
Who cares about comedian?
I'm like, "Am I gonna
be able to date her?"
- I love that y'all
are on the road though.
That's like, I love when
musicians, we do that like
we'll pop up on stage
and surprise the audience
and it's like, the audience
gets like a two for one.
That's awesome.
They probably freak out.
- Seattle was incredible.
it was a lot of people.
And just to see her about to...
'Cause I always tell the DJ
that's gonna announce her to downplay it.
- [Kelly] Yeah? (laughs)
- You know what I mean?
Oh, this next, you're gonna
love her. Ladies and gentlemen.
Chelsea Handler. And they go crazy.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- And it's just, it's fun
to watch that reaction.
- Yeah.
- That element of surprise
of, just like, it's
another slap in the face.
They can't believe that's happening.
- And not to be too cheesy,
but it's gotta be cool to like
feel that energy together,
like on stage.
- Yeah.
- That's cool.
- Together too.
And it's also cool to
go to all these cities
that we get to go to that you
would never normally go to.
- Yeah.
- Like I'm performing
in Louisville, Kentucky
and Birmingham, Alabama.
Like, those aren't places that
are on my list to travel to.
So, it's great.
- Start with that.
- It's great-
- Lead with that.
- But you know what?
- Hey, guys,
I'm only here for this
one night so soak it up.
- I'm only here for your money.
- That was so funny. "I
would never go to Alabama."
- I won't be here unless
it was for a paycheck.
- Oh my God. I swear to God.
You'll kill it if you
start with that. Oh my God.
I love you guys.
You can catch Chelsea Handler and Jo Koy
out on their nationwide tours right now.
Hers is Vaccinated and Horny.
His is, I just love saying it.
His is called Funny is Funny.
Go online for dates and cities for each.
Looking at you, Kentucky. Louisville.
- Yeah!